About a year and a half ago, when my mom was dying, I had this experience that I bring up here because I think it's so common.
大约一年半前，我母亲弥留之际，我有了这样一种经历，之所以在这里提起，是因为我认为这太普遍了。
She and I were in different cities, and I would go see her most weekends when she got sick. It was pretty clear she didn't have a lot of time left. And I kept thinking, we should be having these really big conversations. And I don't even know what it is that I wanted to talk about. It just seemed like anything that we needed to say to each other, we'd better say now before it was too late. But truthfully, it wasn't like we had big issues that needed to be resolving or anything like that. All that stuff had been done years ago.
她和我住在不同的城市，她生病的时候，我几乎每个周末都会去看她。很明显她剩下的时间不多了。我一直在想，我们应该进行一些非常重要的对话。我甚至不知道我想聊些什么。只是觉得如果我们之间有什么话需要对彼此说，最好现在就说，免得为时已晚。但老实说，并不是我们之间有什么需要解决的重大问题之类的。所有那些事情多年前就已经处理好了。
And so I would go. And mostly what she wanted was just company. So we'd watch old movies, and we'd watch TV, and we'd play a little cards and chat about whatever small thing would come up. And at one level, this was fine. It was completely fine. It was fine. And like I say, it was what she wanted.
所以我去了。她想要的主要是陪伴。于是我们一起看老电影，看电视，玩玩纸牌，聊聊随口想到的琐事。从某种层面上讲，这很好。这完全没问题。很好。就像我说的，这正是她想要的。
But at another level, I would sit there intermittently and secretly very anxious that I was wasting this time. That in 6 months or 2 years or 10 years, I was going to look back, and I was going to feel sorry that we had never talked about-- you know what? I didn't even know what we hadn't talked about. I don't know. Like who was her best friend in junior high school, or what her house was like when she was a little girl.
但在另一个层面上，我会断断续续地坐在那儿，暗自非常焦虑，觉得我在浪费这段时间。我在想，6个月后、2年后或者10年后，回首往事，我会因为我们从未谈论过——你知道吗？我甚至不知道我们没谈论过什么。我不知道。比如她在初中时最好的朋友是谁，或者她小时候的家是什么样的。
I have a friend whose father died not too long ago who told me, well, if nothing else, I should use this time to just ask all the questions about all those little stories that I think I might want to know some day. And we did talk about some of that stuff. There were some old stories that I never really had straight that now I know.
我有一个朋友，他的父亲不久前去世了，他告诉我，就算别的什么都不做，我也应该利用这段时间问清楚那些我想在某天了解的琐碎往事。我们确实谈论了一些。有些我以前一直没弄明白的陈年旧事，现在我知道了。
And there were a couple of times sitting on the couch in the middle of some long afternoon where I asked my mom, is there anything that you want to talk about? Is anything that we need to talk about? Anything we need to have resolved or that we need to discuss? And she asked me, why, in my 20s, pretty much through my entire 20s, I was so distant from the family. And I asked her about all the years that she and my dad completely disapproved of my career in public radio. And we talked about these things, we talked about them, I would say, for like, I want to say a total of, I don't know, three minutes. And that pretty much exhausted it as subjects. And then we moved onto the next thing, and that was that.
有几次我坐在沙发上，在漫长的下午中间，我问我妈妈，有什么你想聊的吗？有什么我们需要谈的吗？有什么需要解决或者需要讨论的事情吗？她问我，为什么我在20多岁的时候，几乎整个20多岁，都和家里那么疏远。我问她关于她和我父亲完全不赞同我从事公共广播事业的那几年。我们谈论了这些事情，我们谈论了它们，我会说，总共聊了，我不知道，三分钟吧。这些话题基本就聊完了。然后我们就转到了下一件事，就这样。
Since she died, I've been waiting for the other shoe to drop. I keep waiting for the day that I'm going to be talking to somebody or reading something or watching TV, and suddenly I realize something that I want to ask my mom about. That suddenly I realize what we should have talked about during that stretch of all those weeks, what I should have said back then. I know it's going to happen, and the only question is, is it going to be tomorrow? Or is it going to be the next day? Or is it going to be next month? Or is it going to be next year?
她去世后，我一直等着另一只靴子掉下来。我一直在等哪一天，我在和某人交谈，或者读到什么，或者看电视的时候，突然意识到有什么想问我妈妈的事情。突然意识到在那些周里我们本该谈论些什么，我当时本该说些什么。我知道这迟早会发生，唯一的问题是，会是明天吗？还是后天？还是下个月？还是明年？
I know that people have this kind of feeling about the living also. You know what I mean? They have this feeling about their living friends and relatives, that they wish that they could go back and have do-overs and say something better or say the thing that it took them a really long time to figure out needed to be said. And in my experience-- maybe I'm unusual-- but in my experience, people almost never go back to do that. Even when the people are alive. They never go back and straighten it out and say it.
我知道人们对活人也有这种感觉。你明白我的意思吗？他们对在世的亲友也有这种感觉，希望时光倒流，重来一次，说得更好一点，或者说出他们花了很长时间才想明白需要说的话。根据我的经验——也许我与众不同——但根据我的经验，人们几乎从不回头去那样做。即使对方还活着。他们从不回头去澄清并说出来。
Well, today on our radio program, we have stories about what it would mean to actually go back. What it would mean to finally say everything that you should have said at the time, but that most people never, ever do. We make an unscientific inquiry into that question.
嗯，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们讲述了一些关于真正回头去做意味着什么的故事。最终说出你当时本该说出的话，而大多数人却从未做过，这意味着什么。我们对这个问题进行了一次非科学的调查。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in four time-traveling acts. Act One, Freeze Frame, in which Mr. Jonathan Goldstein, for once in his life, gets to suspend time itself, freeze the hands of time, and finally come up with the right thing to say in some situation.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为四个穿越时空的片段。第一幕，定格，乔纳森·戈尔茨坦先生平生第一次能够暂停时间本身，冻结时间之手，并最终在某种情况下想出了正确的话来说。
Act Two, In The Bush Leagues. We hear the true story of a 20-something activist who heckled the President of the United States, years ago, and failed horribly. President Bush completely bested this guy, leaving him mulling it over late at night for years. Act Three, A Can of Worms. David Sedaris wishes that he could take back a wish in an act. Act Four, Life Sentence, in which the president of the Maryland State Senate, a veteran politician, talks about the off-the-cuff remark that many people say changed his life forever.
第二幕，小联盟。我们听到了一个20多岁的活动家几年前质问美国总统，却惨败的真实故事。布什总统完全压制了这家伙，让他多年来在深夜里反复思量。第三幕，麻烦事。大卫·塞达里斯希望他能在某个举动中收回一个愿望。第四幕，终身监禁，马里兰州参议院院长，一位老资格的政治家，谈论了许多人所说的那句改变他一生的随口之言。
Stay with us.
请继续收听。
Act One, Freeze Frame.
第一幕，定格。
This is the sort of story that I think it's best to introduce the way that you would do a movie trailer. Ladies and gentlemen, if regret has a name-- a name, that is, besides regret-- that name is Jonathan Goldstein. Here he is, with some thoughts and a big plan to change things.
我觉得最好用电影预告片的方式来介绍这个故事。女士们，先生们，如果遗憾有一个名字——一个名字，也就是说，除了遗憾之外——那个名字就是乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。他来了，带着一些想法和一个改变事情的大计划。
Let me start by saying I have pretty much regretted every single thing that's ever come out of my mouth, from my bar mitzvah speech with its inordinate use of the word cherished, to the manner in which I recently responded to my dental hygienist when asked whether the office radio was on too loud. I said, no, it wasn't too loud. "In fact," I said, "it was totally cool." Lord knows where that came from. But once words are out there, they are out there, and there's nothing you can do about it.
首先我要说，我几乎后悔我嘴里说出的每一句话，从我在受戒仪式上过度使用“珍惜”这个词的演讲，到最近我回答牙科保健师问我诊所广播是否太大声时的方式。我说，不，不大。“事实上，”我说，“这太酷了。”天知道那话是从哪儿来的。但一旦话出口了，就是出口了，你什么也做不了。
There are moments where I have misspoken or somehow failed to live up to the occasion that I am capable of replaying in my mind, searching for what I should have said, even years later. These moments have attached themselves to my brain like frightened cats that resist prying. And my capacity for regretting them sometimes feels like the deepest, most enduring part of my personality.
有些时刻我失言了，或者未能达到我本能达到的场合，我会在脑海中重演，寻找我本该说的话，即使是多年后。这些时刻像受惊的猫一样附着在我的大脑上，拒绝离开。我后悔它们的能力有时感觉像是我个性中最深、最持久的部分。
Case in point: about 15 years ago, I was riding a train to Toronto with my girlfriend at the time, when she asked me if I could catch the porter's eye and ask him for a glass of 7UP. I didn't like the idea of bothering the train workers. As a group, they put forth a fair bit of gruff, and I did not like receiving the stuff. In fact, even a tiny little bit of gruff would be enough to ruin my weekend.
举个例子：大约15年前，我和当时的女朋友坐火车去多伦多，她问我能不能引起列车员的注意，帮她要一杯七喜。我不喜欢麻烦铁路工作人员。作为一个群体，他们有点粗鲁，我不喜欢受这种气。事实上，即使是一点点粗鲁也足以毁掉我的周末。
Still, she was my girlfriend, and they had just handed out salted peanuts, and a drink seemed like a pretty good idea. I would probably even end up taking a sip off of hers.
不过，她是我女朋友，而且他们刚分发了咸花生，喝杯饮料听起来是个不错的主意。我可能甚至会最后喝一口她的。
"Why don't you ask him," I said, offering a compromise. And by compromise, I meant I'd sit beside her pretending to be engrossed in a copy of Rolling Stone while she got yelled at.
“你怎么不问他？”我说，提出一个折中方案。所谓的折中，意思是我会坐在她身边假装沉迷于《滚石》杂志，而她则会被吼。
"You should," she said. "You're the man."
“你应该问的，”她说。“你是男人。”
She was right about that. I was the man. An 18-year-old man who was spending his first weekend out of town with a woman. When the porter, who must have easily been at least 75, came moseying by, I craned my head into the aisle and said, just like this, "E-- excuse me, but d-- do you think that maybe I could get a 7UP, please, when you get a chance, if that-- if that's possible?"
她是对的。我是男人。一个18岁的男人，第一次和一个女人在城外度过周末。当那个至少有75岁的列车员晃晃悠悠走过来时，我把头伸进过道，就这样说：“呃——打扰一下，但……你觉得我能不能喝杯七喜，拜托，当你方便的时候，如果那——那可能的话？”
"I already gave you a drink," he said. "There is no second 7UP."
“我已经给你喝过饮料了，”他说。“没有第二杯七喜。”
"No, no, you did," I said. "But that was before the peanuts. Now I need another. Peanuts will do that to a person. Ma-- make them thirsty. I'm-- I'm sorry."
“不，不，你给了，”我说。“但那是在花生之前。现在我需要再来一杯。花生会让人那样。会让——让人口渴。我——我抱歉。”
People turned around and looked at me.
人们转过身看着我。
"There should be a drink before and after the peanuts," I said. "That would be so great. Don't you think that-- that might be a good idea, maybe?"
“花生前后都应该有饮料，”我说。“那会太棒了。你不觉得那——那可能是一个好主意吗，也许？”
All the while as I spoke, my girlfriend sat beside me, falling slowly and imperceptibly more and more out of love with me.
在我说话的时候，我女朋友坐在我身边，缓慢且不易察觉地越来越不爱我了。
When he placed the plastic cup of 7UP down on my tray, he told me hoped it would help me, "wash my nuts down."
当他把那杯塑料杯装的七喜放在我的托盘上时，他告诉我希望这能帮我“把花生冲下去”。
That night in bed, I realized what I should have replied. "My nuts are washed, old timer. Don't worry about me." Several months later, daydreaming in class, I thought of this. I could have lifted up the cup in a toast and said, "To clean nuts." But at the time, all I could think to do was to look down at the tiny, effervescent world within my cup and say thanks. Within the month, my girlfriend and I would be history.
那天晚上在床上，我意识到我本该怎么回答。“我的花生已经冲下去了，老兄。别担心我。”几个月后，在课堂上做白日梦时，我想到了这一点。我本可以举杯祝酒说：“为干净的花生干杯。”但当时，我能想到的唯一一件事就是看着杯子里那微小而起泡的世界说谢谢。一个月内，我和我女朋友就成为了过去式。
If I could stop time, I would not rob the Bank of England, nor would I spend probably more than an afternoon or two studying the hummingbird in mid-flight. I would use my power to freeze time just before I was about to open my mouth to speak. I would get up from wherever I was and pace. I would pace back and forth and perhaps drink a glass of cold water. And once I had crafted the perfect response and steadied my nerves, I would unfreeze time and continue.
如果我能停止时间，我不会去抢劫英格兰银行，也不会花超过一个下午的时间研究飞行中的蜂鸟。我会利用我的力量在开口说话前冻结时间。我会从任何地方站起来踱步。我会来回踱步，也许喝一杯冷水。一旦我想出了完美的回答并稳定了情绪，我就会解冻时间并继续。
Of course, one cannot stop time, but one can stop tape. As an exercise in getting things right, I decided to go through one entire day tape-recording all of my interactions. That way, when the day was over, I would be able to go back over all of my conversations. And by stopping the tape and inserting the right words, I would be able to make everything, finally and for once, perfect. Lord knows saying the right words to people's faces would be far too frightening, but right here, behind their backs on the radio, that would be just right.
当然，人不能停止时间，但可以停止录音带。作为让事情变得正确的练习，我决定花一整天时间录下我所有的互动。这样，当一天结束时，我就能回顾所有的谈话。通过停止录音带并插入正确的话语，我将能够让一切最终变得完美，哪怕只有一次。天知道当面说对的话太吓人了，但在背后，在广播里，那正合适。
So in the morning, I had to go by to my friend Mary's house to babysit her kids. Helen is four, and Katie is two.
所以早上，我得去我朋友玛丽家看她的孩子。海伦四岁，凯蒂两岁。
Silly Johnny.
傻强尼。
This is what the kids do every time they see me. They start chanting. They chant, "Silly Johnny." For them, that is my name. It is what they call me. Silly Johnny.
这就是孩子们每次见到我时做的事。她们开始念口诀。她们念：“傻强尼。”对她们来说，那就是我的名字。她们就是那样叫我的。傻强尼。
Silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly Johnny.
傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼。
OK, hold it right here. There they stand, frozen like porcelain figurines, their mouths frozen wide open, their heads thrown back in cruel delight. And this is what I should have said. I am not the silly one, baby Katie. I could sit down to watch Apocalypse Now with a plate of spicy chicken wings and beer without getting all scarred for life. And I do not have to wear diapers, unless, of course, I choose to. And Helen, can you walk out the door anytime you want, go to an ATM machine, and put a down payment on a leather couch? I don't think so. So who's really silly?
好了，停在这儿。她们站在那儿，像陶瓷塑像一样僵住，嘴巴张得大大的，头因为残酷的愉悦而向后仰。我本该这样说。我不是傻瓜，小凯蒂。我可以一边看《现代启示录》，一边吃着一盘辣鸡翅喝着啤酒，而不会留下心理阴影。而且我不必穿尿布，当然，除非我选择穿。还有海伦，你能随时走出大门，去自动取款机，给皮沙发付定金吗？我不这么认为。所以谁才是傻瓜？
Instead, I said this.
相反，我说了这个。
Silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly Johnny.
傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼。
As you could hear, I said nothing.
正如你听到的，我什么也没说。
Silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly John, silly Johnny, silly Johnny, silly--
傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼，傻强尼，傻——
Mary runs a profitable fancy soap shop, and she's been looking for a part-time employee for months. And every time she starts in about how hard it is to find good help these days, I always tell her how I'd be available to work in the store a few afternoons a week. And then Mary will suddenly remember something she left in the oven. Or she'll change the subject by complimenting me on the sporty-looking jersey I'm wearing, which, truthfully, is not sporty at all or for that matter, even a jersey, unless an undershirt can be called a jersey.
玛丽经营着一家赚钱的高档肥皂店，几个月来她一直在找兼职员工。每次她开始抱怨现在找好帮手有多难时，我总是告诉她我下午有空可以在店里工作几个小时。然后玛丽就会突然想起炉子里放了什么东西。或者她会通过夸奖我穿的运动衫来转移话题，老实说，那衣服一点也不运动，如果内衣也能被称为运动衫的话。
Having most of the morning to watch the kids and brood, I decided that when Mary got back, I was going to broach the subject straight on.
大部分早上时间都在看孩子和沉思，我决定玛丽回来后，我要直接切入主题。
How come you won't have me work for you? You know I would be a good employee, right?
你怎么就不让我为你工作呢？你知道我会是个好员工，对吧？
No, you wouldn't be a good employee.
不，你不会是个好员工。
Now, you see, most people would just drop the subject right here. But I am not most people.
你看，大多数人到这儿就会放弃这个话题了。但我不是大多数人。
You really feel that way?
你真的这么觉得吗？
Yes. The first thing is, you pay no attention. You're completely spaced-out. Plus, you look a little bit ratty, and I think that the women who are coming in to ask you advice about fragrance and the different soaps and how well they wash, I don't think you look the type that would be able to give them some good advice. And you don't follow direction. And you can't multitask.
是啊。首先，你不专心。你完全心不在焉。而且，你看起来有点邋遢，我觉得那些进来向你咨询香水、不同肥皂以及它们洗得有多干净的女性，我不觉得你看起来是那种能给她们好建议的人。而且你不听指挥。你也不能一心多用。
OK, stop the tape right here.
好了，把录音带停在这儿。
You don't respect me, do you?
你不尊重我，是吗？
Um, I think you're a nice person.
嗯，我觉得你是个好人。
Later in the afternoon, I had to drop by the bookstore and pick up, for reasons I won't go into right here, a book on patent law. So when I get to the bookstore, this guy I know, Billy, is there. He doesn't work at the store, but he's there pretty much every time I go in, leaning against the counter and recommending The Master and Margarita to anyone who will listen.
下午晚些时候，我得去书店买一本关于专利法的书，原因我不在这里详述。所以当我到书店时，我认识的一个人，比利，在那儿。他不在这家店工作，但每次我去他基本都在，靠在柜台上向任何愿意听的人推荐《大师和玛格丽特》。
Anyway, in the back of the store, Billy and I get into this discussion about Lord of The Rings. I'm not even sure how we got onto the subject. Billy is one of those guys who in high school used to hang up maps of Middle-earth in his locker. The kind of guy who could sing songs by Simon & Garfunkel in Elvish.
总之，在书店后面，我和比利讨论起《指环王》。我甚至不确定我们是怎么聊到这个话题的。比利是那种高中时会在储物柜里挂中土世界地图的家伙。那种能用精灵语唱西蒙与加芬克尔歌曲的家伙。
I start telling him about how I had just seen the movie, and how Frodo struck me as a little overly emotional about carrying the ring. Sure, the ring tempted people with acts of evil, but so does combining Jack Daniels, insomnia, and the Google search engine. I said I didn't think it would be such a huge deal to carry the ring, at least for a little while. Now, admittedly, our whole argument was ridiculous, but as ridiculous as it was, I was still losing.
我开始告诉他我刚看过这部电影，以及弗罗多在带戒指这件事上给我的印象有点过于情绪化。确实，戒指诱惑人们做出邪恶的行为，但把杰克丹尼、失眠和谷歌搜索引擎结合起来也一样。我说我不觉得带戒指是什么大不了的事，至少带一会儿。现在，不得不承认，我们整个争论很可笑，但尽管可笑，我还是输了。
I give you the Ring of Power, OK? What are you going to do with it, John? What are you doing to do with it?
我把至尊魔戒给你，好吗？你会拿它做什么，约翰？你会拿它做什么？
I--
我——
No question about it. You wouldn't pull it off. You couldn't pull it off. You'd die. Your soul would be taken. Finished, end of story. You wouldn't cut it. You wouldn't cut it on the throne. You wouldn't even be a steward of Gondor. You wouldn't even be one of the Rohirrim? And you want to hold the ring? You couldn't hold the ring, John.
毫无疑问。你撑不住的。你做不到。你会死。你的灵魂会被夺走。完了，故事结束。你不行。你在王位上也不行。你甚至做不了刚铎的宰相。你甚至做不了洛汗骑兵？而你还想持有戒指？你持有不了戒指，约翰。
Now, if I could have just paused things right here, right at this very moment, paced around a bit, shadow-boxed myself towards the right state of mind, I might have found the gumption to say that I didn't even want the stinking ring because all it does is turn you into a pretentious diva anyway. Everyone who holds it becomes Zsa Zsa Gabor. I would have said that even thinking about this ring stuff was for 14-year-old black-hooded Goth kids who strap suede pouches of 20-sided dice from their belts as fashion accessories.
现在，如果我能在这里暂停，就在这一刻，踱步一下，对着自己进行影子拳击，调整到正确的心态，我可能就有勇气说我根本不想要这该死的戒指，因为它只会让你变成一个自命不凡的歌剧名伶。每个持有它的人都会变成莎莎·嘉宝。我会说，甚至连考虑这戒指的事儿都是给那些把20面骰子皮袋子挂在皮带上作为时尚配饰的14岁黑斗篷哥特孩子准备的。
Instead, I answered this way.
相反，我是这样回答的。
Um, I don't know. That's a good question. I don't know.
嗯，我不知道。这是个好问题。我不知道。
To which Billy replied:
对此比利回答道：
You don't know? You don't-- there's even a question? No, Jonathan, you couldn't hold the One Ring of Power. I wouldn't trust you for a second with the Ring of Power. Not for a second.
你不知道？你不知道——这还需要问吗？不，乔纳森，你持有不了至尊魔戒。我一秒钟都不会信任你持有至尊魔戒。一秒钟都不会。
Then I started to backpedal, saying that he was probably right, that I was ill-equipped to hold the ring. I was weak-willed and had little sense of community. I then said that he, Billy, was probably better suited to the task of ring bearer. To which Billy responded:
然后我开始退缩，说他可能是对的，我没能力持有戒指。我意志薄弱，几乎没有集体意识。我接着说他，比利，可能更适合当持戒人。对此比利回答道：
I wouldn't touch the ring, John. OK? Gandalf wouldn't touch the ring. Elrond wouldn't touch the ring. Fools like Boromir tried to touch the ring, but they died. I cannot handle the ring. I am not of Hobbit stock. I don't have that kind of heartiness.
我才不会碰那个戒指，约翰。好吗？甘道夫不会碰戒指。埃尔隆德不会碰戒指。像博罗米尔那样的傻瓜试图碰戒指，但他们死了。我处理不了戒指。我不是霍比特人。我没有那种坚韧的心。
OK, stop right here.
好了，停在这儿。
No, Billy, you don't have that kind of heartiness. You wear yellow sweatpants, and your hands are as smooth as peeled tangerines. You possess the unearthly habit of pulling jaw breakers out of your mouth every five seconds to check what color they are. And whenever you burp, you're compelled to simultaneously speak the word, "Ralph."
不，比利，你没有那种坚韧的心。你穿着黄色运动裤，你的手像剥了皮的橘子一样光滑。你有一种每隔五秒钟就把下巴糖从嘴里拿出来检查它们颜色的怪癖。每当你打嗝，你都忍不住同时说出“拉尔夫”这个词。
But if you're standing there with Billy, looking into his eyes, frozen or not, of course, you don't say anything so mean, despite the fact that you want to. We all carry the ring around inside of us, and that ring is our capacity for wrongdoing. And both he and I, in some way, wish that this capacity could be removed from within us and pounded out into a shiny ring that could be passed around from person to person, allowing us to ease the burden of our urges. Such urges, say, as wanting to voice the really mean things we really think, but in the end, that would be appalling.
但如果你和比利站在一起，看着他的眼睛，无论是否冻结，当然，你不会说这么刻薄的话，尽管你想这么说。我们每个人内心都带着戒指，那戒指就是我们做坏事的能力。我们两个都在某种程度上希望这种能力能从内心移除，并被捶打成一枚闪亮的戒指，可以在人与人之间传递，让我们减轻冲动的负担。比如想把我们真正想到的刻薄话大声说出来的冲动，但归根结底，那太可怕了。
And rather than voicing any of this, I said, instead:
而不是把这些说出来，我反而说了：
Um, I thought-- I don't know.
嗯，我想——我不知道。
Silly Johnny. Silly Johnny.
傻强尼。傻强尼。
In the evening, I had dinner with my parents. I was going to be leaving to New York in a couple of days. And all evening, my father kept bringing up this bottle of vodka he wanted me to buy for him. And all evening, my mother kept cutting him off and yelling at him, louder and angrier as the night wore on. She told him it was impossible for me to get him the bottle, simply impossible. Why she thought it was impossible, I have no idea.
晚上，我和父母一起吃了晚饭。我两天后就要去纽约了。整晚，我父亲一直提起那瓶他想让我给他买的伏特加。整晚，我母亲一直打断他并对他大吼，随着夜晚的推移，声音越来越大，越来越愤怒。她告诉他我给他买那瓶酒是不可能的，简直是不可能。她为什么觉得不可能，我一点也不知道。
But anyway, eventually, my father dropped the subject. But then, after dinner was finished, he started once more.
但总之，最终，我父亲放弃了这个话题。但在晚饭吃完后，他又开始了一次。
It was a good meal, yeah. It was a good meal. But also I would like you to bring me back another bottle of that--
这顿饭很不错，是啊。这是顿好饭。但我也希望你给我带回另一瓶那种——
Could you understand that he can't? It's impossible. Stop that--
你能理解他办不到吗？这不可能。别再——
It's imposs--
这不可能——
Yes. Go on out, and buy yourself what you want.
是的。出去，买你自己想要的东西吧。
You can't Smirnoff's 100 proof--
你不能把斯米诺100度——
He can't get it. He's not going to schlep bottles from New York City for you.
他买不到。他不会为你从纽约市拖运瓶子的。
All right. I have to say one thing, that if I have certain pleasures in life--
好吧。我得说一件事，如果我在生活中确实有一些乐趣——
Who says you need pleasures? You don't need any pleasures. You're too old already for pleasures.
谁说你需要乐趣？你不需要任何乐趣。你年纪太大了，不需要什么乐趣了。
She diminishes my manhood. And she knows where to hit.
她贬低我作为一个男人的尊严。而且她知道打哪里最痛。
OK, Johnny, just have some pineapple now, sweetheart. Sit down and relax. Come eat something.
好了，强尼，现在吃点菠萝，亲爱的。坐下来放松一下。来吃点东西吧。
OK, let's just stop right here. What do you say to that? Even after days of rumination, I still got nothing.
好了，我们就停在这儿。你对此能说什么？即使经过几天的反复思量，我还是什么也说不出。
After dinner, my mother drove me to the bus stop. And in the car along the way, she spoke of how her job was going. My mother works at a daycare, and she really, really loves the kids. She was telling me about how her favorite thing is when the children let her hug them.
晚饭后，我母亲开车送我去汽车站。在车上，她谈起了她的工作进展。我母亲在一家托儿所工作，她真的、真的很爱那些孩子。她告诉我她最喜欢的事情是孩子们让她拥抱他们。
You used to be so mean. I used to beg you for hugs, and you wouldn't give me any. You used to not give hugs.
你以前总是那么刻薄。我曾经乞求你的拥抱，但你从不给我。你以前从来不给拥抱。
I realize now that it must have been difficult to have a child who never let you touch them. In old photographs, you could see me inching away uncomfortably from her hands on my shoulders. At my grade six prom, at the beginning of the mother-son dance, which I still remember as Barbara Streisand and Kris Kristofferson's "You Don't Bring Me Flowers," I refused to dance with her. The whole notion of dancing with your mother in, of all places, your school's gymnasium struck me as unwholesome.
我现在意识到，有一个从不让你触碰的孩子一定很难。在旧照片里，你可以看到我因为她在我的肩膀上而感到不适，正一点点退缩。在我六年级的舞会上，在母子舞的开始，我至今仍记得那是芭芭拉·史翠珊和克里斯·克里斯托佛森的《你不带我去看花》，我拒绝和她跳舞。在那种地方——你学校的健身房里——和母亲跳舞的概念让我觉得不健全。
If there had been a pause button on the dashboard, and I could stop time, stop the flow of traffic entirely so that all the cars beside us on the road became these blurry Monet lily pads, and I could open the passenger door and step out to pace around among them, if I could have sat down on the hood of the car and stared at my mother's face, then maybe I might then have been able to say something better than what I did say, which was this:
如果仪表盘上有一个暂停键，我能停止时间，完全停止交通流，让路上的车都变成莫奈画中模糊的睡莲，如果我能打开副驾驶门走出去在它们中间踱步，如果我能坐在车盖上盯着母亲的脸，那么也许我那时就能说出比我当时所说的更好的话，我当时说的是：
It's really nice the way you talk about the kids in your school. It's-- it-- it-- you know, the-the parents are lucky to have you looking after their kids. You really-- you know, you give them love, you know, which is something that you can't-- you can't really pay someone to love your-- your kids the way that, you know, the way that you would want them to be loved.
你谈论学校里的孩子们的方式真的很棒。那是——那——你知道，家长们有你照看他们的孩子真是幸运。你真的——你知道，你给了他们爱，你知道，这是你不能——你不能真正付钱让某人去爱你的——你的孩子，以那种，你知道，那种你想让他们被爱的方式。
Even as I was saying it, I knew there was a better, more difficult thing to say, namely, I am sorry for never hugging you. Although what I did say wasn't exactly right, at that moment, it felt like the least wrong.
即使在我说的时候，我也知道有一句更好、更难说的话，那就是：对不起，我从未拥抱过你。虽然我所说的不完全正确，但在那一刻，我觉得那是最小的错误。
Life isn't about saying the right thing anyway. And it is certainly not about tape-recording everything so that you have to endure it more than once. Life is about failing. It is about letting the tape play. It is about eating the pineapple you are being force-fed, and, to the best of your ability, enjoying it.
生活本来就不是关于说正确的话。当然，生活也不是关于把一切都录下来，这样你就不得不忍受不止一次。生活是关于失败。是关于让录音带继续播放。是关于吃掉你被强迫喂的菠萝，并尽你所能享受它。
Jonathan Goldstein, author of the novel Lenny Bruce is Dead and host of the CBC radio program Wiretap.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦，小说《莱尼·布鲁斯已死》的作者，加拿大广播公司广播节目《窃听》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "FLY LIKE AN EAGLE" BY THE STEVE MILLER BAND]
[音乐 - 史蒂夫·米勒乐队的《像鹰一样飞翔》]
Act Two, In The Bush Leagues. When he was in his early 20's, barely out of school, at the very first political event of his life, Charles Monroe-Kane got into a shouting match with the leader of the free world. And he pretty much lost that one. This was in the early 1990s. He just left the religious school where he had been studying to be a minister. And he moved to Amsterdam, where he fell in with a bunch of anarchists. He edited an environmental newspaper called the Green Tree News.
第二幕，小联盟。20出头的时候，刚走出校门，在他人生中第一次政治活动上，查尔斯·门罗-凯恩与自由世界的领导人发生了一场争吵。他基本上输了那场争吵。那是90年代初。他刚离开学习成为牧师的宗教学校。他搬到了阿姆斯特丹，在那里他结识了一群无政府主义者。他编辑了一份名为《绿树新闻》的环境报纸。
And I wanted to be an activist, so that's the whole reason I think I wanted to be a minister. I was into liberation theology. That's what I wanted to be.
我想成为一名活动家，所以我认为这就是我想要成为牧师的全部原因。我热衷于解放神学。那才是我想要成为的人。
And I was there about four or five weeks. And the G7 meeting was happening in Munich, Germany. President Bush-- former President Bush, or President Senior, or Dad, whatever you want to call him-- he was president. So we went down like a good activist would do. It was in Munich, Germany. We went down to protest. And I had only been doing this for four or five weeks, so I was kind of down.
我在那儿待了四五周。七国集团会议正在德国慕尼黑举行。布什总统——前总统布什，或者布什老爹，或者爸爸，随你怎么叫他——他是总统。所以我们就去了，像个好的活动家应该做的那样。那是德国慕尼黑。我们去抗议。我做这个才四五周，所以我当时有点……
It was my first political action ever. I was sleeping in the back of a bus with a bunch of dread-locked people. I had my hair down over my shoulders, and I had just gotten my ear pierced. I had a peace sign in my earring. You can imagine the person, right?
这是我人生第一次政治行动。我和一群留着脏辫的人睡在一辆大巴车后面。我的头发垂在肩膀上，我刚打了耳洞。我的耳环上有一个和平标志。你能想象那个人，对吧？
And so basically, we were going down to protest, and I had this press pass. I'm a bit of a talker, bit of a schmoozer. Met some people there, and found out that there are seven levels of press passes. I had level number one, which got you nothing but some faxes. Level number two got you nothing but some faxes, but also got you this buffet once a day. And now I'm sleeping in a bus. I'm like, well, hell, I'm not stupid. So I fandango my way in-- press pass number two.
基本上，我们要去抗议，我有一张媒体证。我挺能说的，挺擅长交际。在那儿遇到了一些人，发现媒体证有七个等级。我有一级证，除了能收到一些传真外什么都没有。二级证除了能收到一些传真外什么都没有，但每天能享用一次自助餐。而现在我睡在大巴里。我想，去你的，我不傻。所以我一路忽悠——弄到了二级媒体证。
Well, of course, food brought me to number three and number four. Now, number five got you a hotel room. I thought, well, my friends could use this. Because we were starting to smell on the second day. So I kept BS-ing my way all the way through just to get these press passes.
嗯，当然，食物把我带到了三级和四级。现在，五级证能让你住进酒店房间。我想，嗯，我的朋友们能用到这个。因为我们在第二天就开始有味道了。所以我一直胡吹乱侃，一路混到了这些媒体证。
Wait, so you get the room?
等等，所以你拿到了房间？
All the way to the sixth level, yeah. I get the room. We get in there-- and the food was awesome, by the way, on the sixth level-- and the suite was-- it was a decent-- it was almost like a suite. It was a decent size where all of us could stay for free.
一直到六级，是的。我拿到了房间。我们进去那里——顺便说一句，六级的食物很棒——套房是——这算是个不错的——它几乎就像一个套房。它大小适中，我们所有人都可以免费住在那儿。
And then what happens is I'm with some people who later became very good friends of mine, but at the time, I didn't know them very well. A friend named Paxus and some others who were high level at Friends of The Earth and Greenpeace. These people are like, "Do you realize what you have? You have a level six press pass at the G7 meeting. You have access to all these places and all these things."
然后发生的事是，我和一些后来成为我很好朋友的人在一起，但当时，我不太了解他们。一个叫帕克苏斯的朋友和其他一些人在“地球之友”和“绿色和平组织”担任高层。这些人说：“你知道你有什么吗？你在七国集团会议上有六级媒体证。你可以进入所有这些地方和所有这些事情。”
"OK, that's cool."
“好吧，那很酷。”
He said, "But what you don't have is you don't have a White House press pass. That's the top level." So he's like, "You know what you ought to do? You ought to try the next level. You should try to get a White House press pass."
他说，“但你没有的是你没有白宫媒体证。那是最高等级。”所以他说，“你知道你应该做什么吗？你应该尝试下一级。你应该试着弄一张白宫媒体证。”
I said, "Why?"
我说，“为什么？”
He said, "Because you could be live at a press conference. You can protest. Tomorrow, George Bush, at 11 o'clock in the morning"-- this is in the afternoon the day before-- "he's giving a live press conference on CNN."
他说，“因为你可以在新闻发布会上直播。你可以抗议。明天，乔治·布什，在上午11点”——这是前一天下午——“他要在CNN上举行现场新闻发布会。”
I was like, "Oh, I never thought of it. I've never done an action before."
我说，“哦，我从来没想过。我以前从来没做过这种行动。”
So I went, and I went to this beer garden where I knew some of the people who made the decisions were. And I met a man named Marlin Fitzwater-- I think a lot of people might know who he is-- and he's sitting there drinking. But I didn't know who the hell he was.
所以我去了，我去了那个啤酒花园，我知道一些做决定的人在那儿。我遇到了一个叫马林·菲茨沃特的人——我想很多人可能知道他是谁——他坐在那儿喝酒。但我不知道这家伙是谁。
The White House Press Secretary.
白宫新闻秘书。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
The actual White House Press Secretary.
真正的白宫新闻秘书。
Because that's the step. Because that's a higher level. The president's got a different security issue.
因为那是步骤。因为那是更高的级别。总统有不同的安全问题。
Well, here's the logic for him, right? He's already assumed I've been checked. Remember, he already knows I have the sixth level press pass, so I'm not like I'm an anarchist in Amsterdam or something like that, for Christ's sake. So I think that he wasn't too worried about that.
好吧，他的逻辑是这样的，对吧？他已经假设我被检查过了。记住，他已经知道我有六级媒体证，所以我不是那种来自阿姆斯特丹的无政府主义者，看在上帝的份上。所以我认为他对此并不太担心。
So then, anyway, he gives me a press pass. It's very exciting. I go back to my hotel room with a bunch of naked, dirty hippies, and I show these people the press pass. And they flip out. They're like, "You're kidding. You got it." I don't understand the ramifications of what's about to happen at all. So basically, they're like, "Well, tomorrow morning, President Bush, at 11 o'clock in the morning, is giving this conference, a press conference live on CNN. You should-- you have a press pass to go there-- I think that you should do something."
总之，他给了我一张媒体证。这太令人兴奋了。我带着一群赤身裸体、肮脏的嬉皮士回到我的酒店房间，给这些人看媒体证。他们都疯了。他们说：“你在开玩笑吧。你拿到了。”我一点也不明白接下来要发生什么的影响。所以基本上，他们说，“嗯，明天早上，布什总统，在上午11点，要举行这个新闻发布会，CNN直播。你应该——你有媒体证去那里——我觉得你应该做点什么。”
I was like, "Well, I agree."
我说，“嗯，我同意。”
So then I sit down with these guys, these guys now who are like-- all the hippie, dirty activists are out of the room, and now I've got the Greenpeace, Friends of the Earth people who know what they're talking about guys. And they're like, "Have you thought about what you're going to say?"
于是我和这些家伙坐下来，这些家伙现在——所有肮脏的嬉皮活动家都出去了，现在我有“地球之友”和“绿色和平组织”那些懂行的人。他们说：“你想好要说什么了吗？”
And I was like, "No, not really."
我说，“不，还没真正想好。”
So we talked about it. And they said, "The most important thing to do is two things. Keep your hands away from your body while you do this, so you don't get shot. Because they might think it's an attempted assassination or something. And you're going to get 20 to 30 seconds max. That's all you're going to get, so know what you're going to say."
所以我们谈论了它。他们说，“最重要的事情是做两件事。当你做这件事时，把你的手放在身体外面，这样你才不会被枪击。因为他们可能会认为这是一次暗杀企图之类的。你最多只有20到30秒。这就是你所有的全部时间，所以知道你要说什么。”
Wait, wait. These are the two pieces of advice they give you? Piece of advice number one is, don't get yourself shot? Like, that's--
等等，等等。这就是他们给你的两条建议？建议第一条是，不要让自己被枪击？就像，那是——
It's good advice, though. And I took it. Because they were like, "Keep your hands away from your body." They said, "Don't wear a watch. Roll up your sleeves, or have on a short-sleeve shirt. You have to be careful. You're in a small room. You're standing up-- basically, you're going to stand up on a chair. Situate yourself in the middle of the room, so you're hard to get at by the Secret Service guys, who are going to, in 15 or 30 seconds, drag you away and arrest you. So what are you going to say?"
这可是个好建议。我也接受了。因为他们说，“把手放在身体外面。”他们说，“不要戴手表。卷起袖子，或者穿短袖衬衫。你必须小心。你在一个小房间里。你站着——基本上，你要站到椅子上。把自己安置在房间中间，这样特勤局的人很难抓住你，他们会在15或30秒内把你拖走并逮捕。所以你要说什么？”
And I thought, "Well, all I know is Christianity."
我想，“嗯，我唯一懂的就是基督教。”
And they said, "Well, that's OK. You can go with that. Americans relate to that."
他们说，“嗯，那没关系。你可以用那个。美国人对此有共鸣。”
And I said, "You know, I've always wanted to be one of the Old Testament prophets. I thought that would be really cool. That's kind of a life dream. That was what I wanted to be."
我说，“你知道，我一直想成为旧约中的先知之一。我觉得那会很酷。那算是人生的梦想。那才是我想要成为的人。”
Now, wait, wait. Now when you say this to a bunch of real activists, "I've always wanted to be one of the Old Testament prophets," is that pretty much where they roll their eyes and slowly shake their heads and look at the ground? They just think, "Oh, what have we gotten ourselves into here?"
现在，等等，等等。当你对一群真正的活动家说“我一直想成为旧约中的先知之一”时，那是他们翻白眼、慢慢摇头看着地面的那种时刻吗？他们只会想，“哦，我们到底卷进什么鬼东西里了？”
No, I think they were more like, "Jesus, this dude's got a White House press pass in his hand, and he is such an idiot. He's so not prepared that we've got to help this kid out. Because we don't have the press pass. He does, and he's the only one who's going to get in."
不，我觉得他们更多是想，“上帝啊，这家伙手里拿着一张白宫媒体证，但他是个彻头彻尾的白痴。他准备得太不充分了，我们得帮帮这孩子。因为我们没有媒体证。只有他有，他是唯一一个能进去的人。”
And so I went to the Bible. And my favorite profit was Jeremiah. And Jeremiah had a certain style. So I think, "Here's what I want to do. I want to get some ashes. I'm going to put some ashes on my head. I want to rip my shirt off, rip it open [MAKES RIPPING SOUND] like that. And I'm going to give him a line from the Old Testament. A good line."
于是我求助于圣经。我最喜欢的先知是耶利米。耶利米有一种特定的风格。所以我心想，“这是我想做的。我想弄点灰烬。我要在头上撒点灰。我要把衬衫撕开 [做撕裂声音] 像那样。然后我要给他念一句旧约里的台词。一句好台词。”
And they said, "Well, maybe you shouldn't quote the Bible. You should do it in that style, something from your thing."
他们说，“嗯，也许你不应该引用圣经。你应该用那种风格，做一些你自己的东西。”
So I thought about it, thought about it, and I came up with this great line. "The homeless in the trees are mourning your economic decisions. Repent, dear King, or go to hell." I thought, "Now, that's a good line." That's good. It's about him, but it takes inanimate objects into effect. I'm an environmental activist as well. So I said, "That's what I'm going to do."
所以我想了又想，想到了这句棒极了的台词。“树上的无家可归者在哀悼你的经济决策。忏悔吧，亲爱的国王，否则下地狱吧。”我想，“现在，那是一句好台词。”那很好。那是关于他的，但它把无生命物体考虑在内。我也是环境活动家。所以我说，“这就是我要做的。”
Now Charles, can we just pause the story right here--
现在查尔斯，我们可以把故事暂停在这儿吗——
Absolutely.
当然。
And let's move to the present, a dozen years later. Now, when you think about that quote now, as the adult you are, how do you view that quote now?
让我们跳到现在的十二年后。当你作为一个成年人回顾那句引语时，你现在怎么看那句话？
Oh, my god, it's the most embarrassing choice of anything I would ever use in my life. If I had 30 seconds to choose now, I think I would say something maybe a little bit more, a little less, whatever-- symbolic, I don't know. But that's what I had. I was 22, and that's all I knew.
噢，天哪，这是我人生中最尴尬的选择。如果我现在有30秒的时间选择，我想我会说一些稍微多一点，稍微少一点，不管是什么——象征性的，我不知道。但那就是我当时拥有的。我才22岁，那就是我所知道的一切。
So I practiced it over and over again. "The homeless in the trees are mourning your economic decisions. Repent, dear King, or go to hell. The homeless in the trees are mourning your economic decisions. Repent, dear King, or go to hell." Hands away from my body.
所以我反复练习。 “树上的无家可归者在哀悼你的经济决策。忏悔吧，亲爱的国王，否则下地狱吧。树上的无家可归者在哀悼你的经济决策。忏悔吧，亲爱的国王，否则下地狱吧。” 手放在身体外面。
But then one of the activists guys came up with a great idea, this American guy. He was like, "Well, don't rip your clothes because that's going to get misunderstood. You should rip an American flag in half. And that should be the cloth that you rip."
但后来其中一个活动家家伙想出了个好主意，这个美国家伙。他说，“嗯，别撕你的衣服，因为那会被误解。你应该把一面美国国旗撕成两半。那应该是你撕开的布料。”
I said, "That's a great idea." So I'm going to put ashes on my forehead, I'm going to rip an American flag in half, I'm going to read that statement, yell it out with all the passion I can muster, get arrested, and awesome!
我说，“那是个好主意。” 所以我要把灰撒在额头上，我要把一面美国国旗撕成两半，我要念出那段声明，用我能鼓起的全部热情喊出来，被逮捕，简直太棒了！
Wait. Have you ever-- you've lived in the United States of America, right?
等等。你曾经——你住在美国，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you familiar with how people feel about the ripping in half of the American flag?
你熟悉人们对把美国国旗撕成两半的感受吗？
That's probably part of the reason he liked and I liked it, I think, at the time.
那可能就是他喜欢它、我也喜欢它的原因之一，我想，当时。
But weren't you trying to win the sympathies of your countrymen?
但你不是在试图赢得同胞的同情吗？
Yeah, I think I was. But I also think I was-- I don't know what I was trying to do, man-- I was 22. When you were 22, did you know what you were trying to do? Good Lord, I don't know I was trying to do.
是啊，我想我是在试图。但我还觉得我是在——我不知道我在试图做什么，伙计——我才22岁。你22岁的时候，你知道你在做什么吗？天哪，我不知道我在做什么。
So I couldn't sleep that night. They were right. I couldn't sleep. I was a little nervous. And they got me a shirt and a pair of pants. Some shoes that fit me. We had to go to different activists to find it all. A nice tie. I took the earring out. They had a lawyer for me. I gave him my passport. Nothing in my pockets. But shoved down the front of my pants is an American flag-- partly ripped on the top, so I could easily rip it in half-- and some ashes in my pocket.
所以我那天晚上没睡着。他们是对的。我睡不着。我有点紧张。他们给我弄了一件衬衫和一条裤子。一些合脚的鞋子。我们不得不去找不同的活动家才凑齐。一条漂亮的领带。我摘掉了耳环。他们为我找了个律师。我交出了护照。口袋里什么都没有。但我裤子前面塞着一面美国国旗——顶部已经撕开了一点，这样我就可以很容易地把它撕成两半——口袋里还有些灰烬。
And this quote burned into my brain. It was like a zen-- I don't even know what zen is at the time-- I do now. But at the time, it was a zen mantra. "The homeless in the trees are mourning your economic decisions. Repent, dear King, or go to hell." And that's all I had in my mind.
这句话刻进了我的大脑。那就像一个禅——我当时甚至不知道什么是禅——我现在知道了。但当时，那是一个禅的口诀。“树上的无家可归者在哀悼你的经济决策。忏悔吧，亲爱的国王，否则下地狱吧。” 我脑子里就只有这些。
So I go into the press conference saying, you know-- and a former Christian kid, here I am. So I sit down. I situate myself in the middle of the room. There's about 44, 45 people. And I remember counting them. I was nervous, so I counted all the people. My throat was dry, and I thought I was going to pass out. And I didn't want to throw up. I knew that would be bad. That wouldn't be a good symbol. And I didn't want to pass out.
所以我走进新闻发布会时说，你知道——作为一个前基督教的孩子，我在这里。所以我坐下。我把自己安置在房间中间。大约有44、45个人。我记得我数了他们。我当时很紧张，所以我数了所有人。我的喉咙很干，我想我要晕过去了。我不想要呕吐。我知道那会很糟。那不是一个好象征。我也不想晕过去。
So it's coming up to the point. My heart's aflutter.
所以快到那个点了。我的心在狂跳。
Well, let me stop you right there. Because we have here in the studio a videotape of this day, July 8, 1992. We got this courtesy of the Vanderbilt University Television Archives. And you have never seen this?
好了，我在这儿打断你。因为我们在演播室里有这一天，1992年7月8日的录像带。这是范德比尔特大学电视档案馆提供的。你从没看过这个？
No, I've never seen it. I've never even seen the highlights from any of the news. All I've seen is newspaper stuff. I'm really nervous about watching this.
不，我从没看过。我甚至没看过任何新闻片段。我只见过报纸上的东西。看这个我真的很紧张。
OK. Let's roll the tape.
好吧。放带子吧。
Right now, let's go live to Munich to hear President Bush's comments at the close of the G7 summit.
现在，让我们连线慕尼黑，听听布什总统在七国集团峰会结束时的评论。
I totally remember that, him coming in. That was intense.
我完全记得那次，他走进来。那太紧张了。
--the last three days discussing the responsibilities and opportunities that we had--
——过去三天讨论我们所承担的责任和机会——
Because that's the point where I'm sitting there with a flag between my legs I'm going rip in half and yell at the man, the President of the United States. Oh my god, it makes me want to pass out. All right. Sorry.
因为那是我坐着，裤子里塞着一面我要撕成两半并对那个人、美国总统大喊的旗子的时候。天哪，那让我想晕过去。好吧。抱歉。
--sustaining political reform. I would cite five key accomplishments at the Munich Economic Summit. We've succeeded in achieving a solid consensus on strengthening--
——维持政治改革。我想引用慕尼黑经济峰会的五项关键成就。我们成功地在加强方面达成了坚实的共识——
Now, he's barely spoken for a half minute. He's still in his opening statement.
现在，他才说了半分钟不到。他还在开场白阶段。
--United States, Japan,
——美国，日本，
[YELLING IN THE BACKGROUND]
[背景中的尖叫声]
Germany, and Italy have--
德国，和意大利已经——
Now the camera's panning back.
现在镜头移开了。
Repent. We mourn your decisions here. You're not giving us your voice.
忏悔吧。我们在哀悼你的决策。你没给我们你的声音。
Oh my god, look at that kid. Wow, you can't even hear the great line, "The homeless in the trees are mourning your decisions here."
天哪，看看那个孩子。哇，你甚至听不清那句伟大的台词，“树上的无家可归者在哀悼你的决策。”
You can't hear it all. You can't hear it at all. All you hear is the president.
你一点也听不见。你一点也听不见。你只听得到总统。
Oh, I didn't even notice that. I didn't even know that. What if nobody heard it? I guess not. This is the tape.
哦，我甚至没注意到这点。我甚至不知道这点。要是没人听到呢？我想没有。这就是带子。
This is the tape. I don't think anybody heard it.
这就是带子。我觉得没人听到。
Wow. That's intense.
哇。那太紧张了。
I'm trying to give--
我正试图给出——
[INAUDIBLE] your voice in the US.
[听不清] 你在美国的声音。
I'm trying to give you my voice right now. And if you'd be quiet, maybe you could hear it.
我正试图现在就把我的声音给你。如果你安静点，也许你能听见。
But you're not giving it to us [INAUDIBLE].
但你没给我们你的声音 [听不清]。
Well, would you please sit down? We're in the middle of a press conference here.
你是谁，你代表谁？
You're not giving us your voice there.
你没在那里给我们你的声音。
Well, what's your question, sir?
好吧，你的问题是什么，先生？
I'm under 25, and I want to know--
我不到25岁，我想知道——
Well, we can tell that.
嗯，我们看得出来。
Nice. Good for him. He got me on that one.
好。干得好。他在那一点上抓住了我。
Now, what's your question?
现在，你的问题是什么？
Now, this I remember. Because I just assumed I was going to be arrested. I knew I wasn't going to be shot. That hadn't happened yet, so that's cool. And I'm like, "This is it." And what happened next was amazing because nothing happened next.
这个我记得。因为我只是假设我会被逮捕。我知道我不会被枪击。那还没发生，所以那很好。我想，“就是现在了。” 接下来发生的事情很惊人，因为接下来什么也没发生。
I didn't get arrested. He had this thing where he had his hands on the podium, and he kind of moved his hands. I don't know what signals they have, or whatever, but they didn't arrest me. And then the worst possible thing in the world happened to me. He ain't going to arrest me, and he's about to engage me. And I was like, "Oh, my god. The President of the United States is speaking to me right now, and he basically started asking me questions. And I was like, "Holy mackerel." I really almost passed out.
我没被逮捕。他把手放在讲台上，他移动了一下手。我不知道他们有什么信号，不管怎样，他们没逮捕我。然后世界上最糟糕的事情发生了。他没逮捕我，而且他打算和我互动。我想，“噢，天哪。美国总统正在跟我说话，他基本上开始问我问题了。我当时觉得，‘天哪。’ 我真的差点晕过去。”
Who are you, and who are you accredited to?
你是谁？你受谁的委托？
My name is Charles Kane.
我的名字是查尔斯·凯恩。
Yeah.
是啊。
I'm from the United States.
我来自美国。
Yeah.
是啊。
I work with a magazine in the Netherlands. It's a youth magazine. And we want to know why we're not taken seriously. We're an environmental group.
我在荷兰的一本杂志工作。那是一本青年杂志。我们想知道为什么我们没被认真对待。我们是一个环保组织。
Well, maybe you're rude. People don't take rude people seriously. And if you interrupt a press conference like this, I'm sure that people would say that's why we don't take you seriously.
嗯，也许你很粗鲁。人们不把粗鲁的人当回事。如果你像这样打断新闻发布会，我相信人们会说这就是我们不把你当回事的原因。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Sit down, and I will take a question from you when we get in the question and answer period. Right now, I would like to continue my statement with your permission.
坐下，等我们到了提问环节我会回答你的问题。现在，请允许我继续我的陈述。
Thank you, Captain. Go ahead.
谢谢你，队长。请继续。
Now, where were we? We were talking about economic recovery. [CHUCKLES]
现在，我们刚才聊到哪儿了？我们刚才在谈论经济复苏。 [轻笑]
So the President gives this little nervous laugh and sort of looks down, and then he goes on with his regular statement.
所以总统发出这种神经质的笑声，然后向下看，接着继续他的常规陈述。
Oh my god.
天哪。
And this continues for a few minutes.
这种情况持续了几分钟。
So I'm sitting down, That's all. I don't remember.
所以我坐下了，仅此而已。我不记得了。
So you're sitting down.
所以你坐下了。
Why didn't I keep yelling? What a wimp. I guess I was probably-- but he gave me a cue there.
为什么我没继续大喊？真是个懦夫。我猜我可能——但他给了我一个暗示。
Well, what do you mean why-- What he was saying was perfectly reasonable. "I'll get to you during the question-- look, we're going to talk, and it's going to be during the question and answer period. I'm just reading my opening statement." How are you going to argue with that?
好吧，你说的“为什么”是什么意思——他所说的是完全合理的。“我会等提问环节再找你——看，我们要聊的，这会在问答环节进行。我只是在读我的开场白。”你怎么能反驳这个？
Yeah, but it's a protest. I was supposed to be in there yelling at him. I was supposed to get arrested. I thought I was supposed to get arrested.
是啊，但这可是抗议。我本应该在那儿对他大喊大叫的。我本应该被逮捕的。我以为我本应该被逮捕。
Oh my god, I so didn't want to be there after I didn't get arrested. I was so embarrassed. It was horrible.
天哪，在没被逮捕后，我是多么不想待在那儿啊。我太尴尬了。那太可怕了。
Because from your point of view, the whole point was to get arrested.
因为从你的角度看，整个目的就是为了被逮捕。
Yes.
是的。
So now at this point, you've failed.
所以现在在这一点上，你失败了。
Well, also, I not only failed at that point for not getting arrested, I also know I'm going to fail because he's going to ask a question to me later. Because I don't have anything to say. I mean, you've got to remember that. I don't have anything to say. I don't have a question. What do you mean, I have a question? Of course, I don't have a question.
嗯，还有，我不但在那一刻因为没被逮捕而失败，我也知道我要失败了，因为他之后会问我一个问题。因为我没什么可说的。我的意思是，你得记住这一点。我没什么可说的。我没有问题。你说的“我有一个问题”是什么意思？当然，我没有问题。
So finally it comes to you. You're the third question. And basically, he answers two questions, and then he says this.
所以最后轮到你了。你是第三个问题。基本上，他回答了两个问题，然后他说了这个。
And that's what we're talking about. Now, let's go to this gentleman who's so agitated here.
而这就是我们正在谈论的。现在，让我们去问问这位非常激动的绅士。
I just want to know why there's no new nuclear power plants in the United States being built, but you're proposing for Siemens to build them in Eastern Europe?
我只是想知道为什么美国没有在建新的核电站，而你却提议让西门子在东欧建造它们？
Oh, I'd like some more to be built.
噢，我希望多建一些。
Why are they so unsafe in our country and so safe in their country?
为什么它们在我国不安全，而在他们国家却安全？
Well, I don't think they're un--
嗯，我不认为它们不——
Why it is only at the G7--
为什么只有在七国集团——
You've asked your question, sir. Now let me try to answer it for you. I favor nuclear power. I believe that it can be safely used. I believe that it is environmentally sound. The debate here has been that we ought to try to help those areas that have nuclear facilities that might not have the latest technology and might not meet the same standards of safety that we use in our country. Thank you very much. Now, we'll go here.
你已经问过你的问题了，先生。现在让我试着为你回答它。我支持核能。我相信它可以被安全地利用。我相信它在环保方面是合理的。这里的辩论是我们应该尝试帮助那些拥有可能没有最新技术、可能不符合我们在我国使用的相同安全标准的核设施的地区。非常感谢。现在，我们到这里。
Do you respect the flag?
你尊重国旗吗？
Then you said, "Do you respect the flag?"
然后你说，“你尊重国旗吗？”
You had your question.
你已经问过你的问题了。
Oh, now the media is yelling at me.
噢，现在媒体在对我大喊大叫。
[CROWD YELLING]
[人群叫喊声]
It's all rhetoric. Come on, you guys, think about it.
那全是修辞。来吧，你们这些人，想想看。
And then you say, "It's all rhetoric."
然后你说，“那全是修辞。”
Is the world going to be a better place in a year?
一年后世界会变得更美好吗？
This is coming out of your time, gang, and we've got 20 minutes here.
这在浪费你的时间，伙计们，我们在这儿有20分钟。
This is a press conference, man.
这是新闻发布会，伙计。
Come on. This [UNINTELLIGIBLE] acting up at all.
来吧。这个 [听不清] 根本没起到什么作用。
Mr. President--
总统先生——
You guys are all part of this system too.
你们这些人也是这个系统的一部分。
And then the president sort of laughs.
然后总统笑了笑。
Thanks a lot. Go ahead.
多谢。请继续。
Much has been said here by you and others about the--
你和其他人在这里说了关于——
We've given up.
我们放弃了。
And then there's the voice of Sam Donaldson. And then now, it's back to normal.
然后是萨姆·唐纳森的声音。然后现在，一切恢复正常了。
God, I can't believe I did that. That's embarrassing. It's so hot in here. I'm totally embarrassed by that. Oh my god. I mean, I'm not embarrassed about yelling at the President of the United States. I do not sit here right now and say, "Wow, I wish I wouldn't have done it." No way. I sit here right now and say, "I wish I would have done it down better."
天哪，我不敢相信我竟然做了那样的事。那太尴尬了。这儿太热了。我对那感到非常尴尬。天哪。我的意思是，我不尴尬大喊美国总统这件事。我不坐在现在这里说，“哇，我希望我没那样做。”绝对没有。我坐在现在这里说，“我希望我当时做得更好。”
And what would doing a better job have meant? What do you wish that you would have said?
而做得更好意味着什么？你希望你当时会说什么？
I wish I would have said something that kind of hung in the air for a moment, that made everybody silent, that would keep him awake for one moment of his life, that just would make him think, "Wow, I do have some responsibility, and I have squandered that responsibility."
我希望我说出一些会在那一刻悬在空气中、让每个人都沉默、能让他清醒哪怕一刻的话，那只会让他想，“哇，我确实有一些责任，而我浪费了那份责任。”
But what could that possibly be?
但那可能是什么呢？
I don't know. Haven't you been touched by one statement in your life that's affected you greatly? I have.
我不知道。难道你的人生中没有被哪一句话深刻影响过吗？我有。
Yes, but it's--
是的，但它是——
So I'm giving him credit.
所以我正在给他信用。
It seems very unlikely in this setting.
在这个环境中似乎非常不可能。
Now, in retrospect, it's extremely unlikely. It's probably a million to one, but you got to try. You got to try
现在，回想起来，这极不可能。这可能是百万分之一的概率，但你得尝试。你得尝试。
I don't know. When I see the president answering questions at a news conference, I feel like what he's doing is-- he doesn't want to say anything that's going to get him in trouble. He doesn't want to say anything that's going to make his life more complicated and difficult. And it's not an environment conducive to learning.
我不知道。当我看到总统在新闻发布会上回答问题时，我觉得他在做的是——他不想说任何会让他陷入麻烦的话。他不想说任何会让他的生活变得更复杂和困难的话。这不是一个有利于学习的环境。
What I should have said is-- when I think about it at 3 o'clock in the morning, it's not the-- it's in general what I should have said. I should have said something that would affect the man's life. And what's depressing for me that really makes me sad is that I still haven't come up with what I should have said. And that really makes me sad.
我本该说的是——当我在凌晨三点想到它时，这不是——这通常是我本该说的。我本该说些会影响那个人生活的话。真正让我感到沮丧、真正让我难过的是，我还没想出我本该说什么。这真的让我很难过。
But of course, you didn't come up with what you should have said because nothing could have been said--
但当然，你没想出你本该说什么，因为什么也说不出来——
I won't accept that--
我不接受这点——
In that setting that was going to make the President of the United States rethink anything in particular.
在那个环境下，能让美国总统反思任何特别的事情。
I won't accept that. I should have found something that could have changed the world at that moment. I had my opportunity at that moment. I think I should have gone for it.
我不接受这点。我本该找到能在那一刻改变世界的东西。我在那一刻有机会。我觉得我本该去尝试。
Now, you're in your thirties now. Have you ever had this experience where somebody just yelled something at you, some punk kid, whatever, yelled at you?
现在，你三十多岁了。你有过这样的经历吗，有人冲你大喊大叫，什么小混混，什么的，冲你大喊？
I did. I was at an introduction. I was introducing somebody who was about to give a speech. They heckled me. It was a really interesting experience because immediately what came back was me.
我有过。我在一次介绍会上。我正在介绍一位即将发表演讲的人。他们嘲讽我。那是一次非常有趣的经历，因为立刻回击的是我自己。
Did it keep you up at night afterwards? Did it give you something to think about?
那让你之后彻夜难眠吗？那给了你什么思考的东西吗？
That's an unfair-- of course, no, it didn't give me anything to think about. No, it didn't keep me up at night at all. It didn't-- yeah, I get your-- that's a good question. No, it didn't keep me up at all.
那是个不公平的——当然，没有，它没给我任何思考的东西。没有，它根本没让我彻夜难眠。它没——是啊，我明白了你的意思——那是个好问题。没有，它根本没让我晚上睡不着。
And so do you think, thinking about George Bush and the possibility that he would be kept up at night a moment like this--
所以你觉得，考虑到乔治·布什以及他可能会因为像这样的时刻而彻夜难眠的可能性——
No. No, OK, I understand where you're going. I respect where you're going. No, of course not. But I know this all along. Yeah, I know this all along. It's only what you wish would have happened. I hope-- I don't know. Maybe I'll read his memoirs, and he'll say, "You know--"
不。不，好吧，我明白你的意思了。我尊重你的方向。不，当然不会。但我一直都知道这一点。是啊，我一直都知道这一点。那只是你希望发生的事情。我希望——我不知道。也许我会读他的回忆录，他会说，“你知道——”
OK, forget it. I won't even go there. I tried, man. It was a tough day, man. It was a tough day. I tried really. I did my best. My best wasn't very good at the time, but I tried my best.
好吧，算了吧。我甚至不想去那儿。我尝试过了，伙计。那是个艰难的一天，伙计。那是个艰难的一天。我确实尽力了。我的全力当时并不是很好，但我尽力了。
Charles Monroe-Kane. He's a producer for the public radio program To The Best of Our Knowledge. Coming up, David Sedaris and When You Wish Upon A Pie. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
查尔斯·门罗-凯恩。他是公共广播节目《尽我们所知》的制作人。接下来是戴维·塞达里斯和《当你向派许愿》。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, What I Should've Said. Stories where people go back in time, rethink the moments that have vexed them. We have arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, A Can Of Worms. David Sedaris told this next story before a live audience.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“我本该说的话”。人们回到过去，重新思考那些困扰他们的时刻的故事。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，麻烦事。戴维·塞达里斯在一个现场观众面前讲述了这下一个故事。
Hugh wanted hamburgers. So he, his friend Anne, and I went to a place called The Apple Pan. This was in Los Angeles. I thought The Apple Pan would be a restaurant, but it was more like a diner. No tables, just stools arranged along a u-shaped counter.
休想吃汉堡。所以他、他的朋友安和我去了叫“苹果锅”的地方。那是在洛杉矶。我以为“苹果锅”会是一家餐馆，但它更像个小饭店。没有桌子，只有沿着U型柜台排列的凳子。
We ordered our hamburgers from a man in a paper hat. And while waiting for them to arrive, Anne pulled out some pictures of her bull terrier. She's a professional photographer, and so they were portraits rather than snapshots. Here was the dog peeking out from behind a curtain. Here was the dog sitting human style in an easy chair, a paw resting on the paunch of his stomach.
我们从一个戴纸帽子的男人那里点了汉堡。在等待它们到来时，安拿出了她牛头梗的照片。她是专业摄影师，所以它们是肖像照而不是快照。这里是狗从窗帘后面探出头来。这里是狗像人一样坐在一把扶手椅上，一只爪子放在肚子上。
When she's not taking pictures of her dog, Anne flies around the country on assignment from various magazines. A day earlier, she'd returned from Boston where she photographed the fire commissioner, whose last name is Bastardo. "That's bastard with an O on the end," she said. "Don't you think that's funny?" Hugh told her about some neighbors in Normandy whose last name translates to hot ass. But unless you speak French, it's hard to get the joke.
当她不拍她的狗时，安会受各种杂志的指派飞往全国各地。前一天，她从波士顿回来，在那里她拍摄了消防专员，他的姓是巴斯塔多。“那是混蛋（bastard）加个O在后面，”她说。“你不觉得这很有趣吗？” 休告诉她关于诺曼底的一些邻居，他们的姓翻译过来是“热屁股”（hot ass）。但除非你会法语，否则很难理解这个笑话。
"Is that hyphenated," Anne asked. "I mean, did Miss Hot marry Mr. Ass, or is it all one word?"
“那是连字符的吗？”安问。“我的意思是，是小小姐嫁给了屁股先生，还是它是一个词？”
I thought the conversation would rest here for a while, and so I prepared myself to contribute, wary of how easy it is to fall into a game of one-upsmanship. If you knew a Candy Dick, the other person is bound to have known a Harry Dick or a Dick Eater. I'd recently learned of the race car driver Dick Trickle. But for the time being, we were operating on a higher plane.
我以为谈话会在这里停留一会儿，所以我准备参与，小心翼翼地想避免陷入某种攀比游戏。如果你认识一个Candy Dick（姓氏），对方注定认识一个Harry Dick或者Dick Eater。我最近听说过赛车手迪克·特里克尔（Dick Trickle）。但目前，我们在更高的平面上运作。
Anne's last name is Fishbein, and she hates it. She and Hugh met in college, and when our hamburgers arrived, they reminisced about some of the people they had gone to school with. "What was that guy's name? I think he was in the art department. Mike maybe, or Mark? He used to go out with Karen, I think her name was. Or Kimberly. You know who I mean?" Talk like this can go on for a while. And while you do have to accept it, you don't have to actually pay attention.
安的姓是费什拜因，她讨厌它。她和休在大学里认识，当我们的汉堡上来时，他们回忆起了一些他们一起上过学的同学。“那家伙叫什么名字来着？我觉得他在艺术系。迈克也许，还是马克？他曾经和凯伦约会过，我想她叫那个名字。还是金伯利。你知道我说的是谁吗？” 这样的对话可以持续一会儿。虽然你确实得接受它，但你不需要真正去注意它。
I stared straight ahead, watching a broken-nosed cook top a hamburger with cheese. And then I turned slightly to my left and began listening to the two men seated on the other side of me. The man beside me wore a t-shirt endorsing the state of Florida. And as if the weather were completely different on the other side of the ketchup bottle, the man beside him wore a thick wool sweater and heavy corduroy pants. A coat rested in his lap, and before him on the counter sat a newspaper and an empty cup of coffee.
我盯着前方，看着一个塌鼻子的厨师在汉堡上加芝士。然后我稍微向左转，开始听坐在我另一边的两个男人说话。坐在我旁边的男人穿着一件支持佛罗里达州的T恤。好像番茄酱瓶子另一边的天气完全不同似的，他旁边的男人穿着一件厚羊毛衫和粗灯芯绒裤。外套放在他的膝盖上，在他面前的柜台上放着一份报纸和一杯喝光的咖啡。
"Did you read about those worms," he asked? He was referring to the can of nematodes, tiny worms recently discovered on the Texas plains. They'd been sent up with the doomed space shuttle and had somehow managed to survive the explosion, the cause of which was still a mystery. The man in the sweater massaged his chin and stared into space.
“你读过关于那些虫子的报道吗？”他问。他指的是线虫罐头，最近在德克萨斯平原发现的微小蠕虫。它们曾随注定毁灭的航天飞机被送上天，并以某种方式在爆炸中幸存下来，爆炸的原因仍然是个谜。穿羊毛衫的男人按摩着下巴，盯着虚空。
"I've been thinking we could solve this problem in no time," he said, "if only, if only we could get the damn things to talk." It sounded crazy, but I remember thinking the exact same thing about the Akita in the O.J. Simpson case.
“我一直在想，我们可以迅速解决这个问题，”他说，“只要，只要我们能让这些该死的东西说话。” 这听起来很疯狂，但我记得在O.J.辛普森案中的秋田犬身上想过同样的事情。
"Put it on the stand. Let's hear what it's got to say." It was one of those ideas that just for a split second seemed entirely logical, the one solution that nobody had thought of. The man in the t-shirt considered the possibility.
“把它放在证人席上。让我们听听它有什么要说的。” 这是那种想法，在那一瞬间看起来完全合理，这是没人想到的唯一解决方案。穿T恤的男人考虑了这种可能性。
"Well," he said, "even if the worms could talk, it wouldn't do much good. They was in that can, remember?"
“嗯，”他说，“即使蠕虫会说话，也没什么用。它们在那个罐子里，记得吗？”
"I guess you're right."
“我想你是对的。”
The men stood to pay their bills. And before they reached the door, their stools were taken by two people who did not know one another. One was a man dressed in a fine suit, and the other, a young woman who sat down and immediately started reading what looked to be a script. Over on my right, Hugh had decided that rather than Karen or Kimberly, the classmate had been named Katherine.
男人们站起来去结账。在他们到达门口之前，他们的凳子被两个互不认识的人占领了。一个是身穿名牌西装的男人，另一个是年轻女子，她坐下后立刻开始阅读看起来像是剧本的东西。在我的右边，休已经决定，比起凯伦或金伯利，那个同学叫凯瑟琳。
While I'd been listening to my neighbors, he had ordered me a piece of pie. And as I picked up my fork, Anne told me that I was supposed to eat it backwards, starting with the outer crust and working my way inward.
当我在听邻居谈话时，他已经帮我点了一块派。当我拿起叉子时，安告诉我我应该从反面吃，从外壳开始，然后向内吃。
"Your last bite should be the point, and you're supposed to make a wish on it," she said. "Hasn't anyone ever told you that?"
“你的最后一口应该是尖儿，你应该对着它许个愿，”她说。“从来没人告诉过你吗？”
"Come again?"
“再说一遍？”
Anne looked at me the way you might at someone who regularly tosses money into the fire. The senselessness, the waste.
安看着我的眼神，就像看一个经常把钱扔进火里的人一样。那种愚蠢，那种浪费。
"Well, better late than never," she said. And she repositioned my plate.
“嗯，迟做总比不做好，”她说。然后她重新摆放了我的盘子。
As she and Hugh resumed their conversation, I thought of all the pie I had eaten during the course of my life, and I wondered how different things might be if only I had wished upon the points. To begin with, I would not be seated at The Apple Pan. That much was certain. Had I gotten my wish at the age of eight, I would still be rounding up mummies in Egypt, luring them from their tombs and trapping them in heavy iron cages. All subsequent wishes would have been based upon the life I had already established. A new set of boots. A finer whip. Greater command of the mummy language.
当她和休恢复谈话时，我想起了我一生中吃过的所有派，我好奇如果我早些时候对着尖儿许愿，事情会有什么不同。首先，我不会坐在“苹果锅”。那是肯定的。如果我在八岁时就许了愿，我可能还在埃及搜寻木乃伊，把它们引出坟墓并把它们困在沉重的铁笼里。所有随后的愿望都将建立在我已经建立的生活基础上。一套新靴子。一条更好的鞭子。对木乃伊语言更好的掌握。
That's the problem with wishes. They ensnare you. In fairy tales, they're nothing but trouble, magnifying the greed and vanity of the person for whom they are granted. One's best bet, and the moral to all those stories, is to be unselfish and make your wish for the benefit of others, trusting that their happiness will make you happy as well. That'll be the day.
这就是愿望的问题所在。它们会困住你。在童话故事中，它们除了麻烦什么都不是，只会放大被授予愿望的人的贪婪和虚荣。一个人最好的赌注，也是所有这些故事的道德所在，是无私并为他人的利益许愿，相信他们的幸福也会让你幸福。那才怪呢。
Since we'd entered, The Apple Pan had grown progressively busier. All the seats were now taken. And people leaned against the wall, their eyes moving from stool to stool, determining which customers should pay up and get out. Looking around, I saw that we were the likeliest candidates. The man in the hat had removed our hamburger wrappers, and all that remained was a single plate supporting the tip of my pie. I wished that the people against the wall would stop staring at us, and then quickly, but not quick enough, I tried to take it back.
自从我们进来以后，“苹果锅”已经变得越来越忙碌。所有的座位现在都满了。人们靠在墙上，眼睛在凳子之间移动，确定哪些顾客应该付账离开。环顾四周，我看到我们是最可能的候选人。那个戴帽子的男人已经收走了我们的汉堡包装纸，剩下的只有支持我派尖儿的一个盘子。我希望靠在墙上的人别再盯着我们看了，然后很快，但不够快，我试图收回那个愿望。
"I guess we should get going," Hugh said, and he and Anne pulled out their wallets. There was a little struggle over who would pay. "It's my treat." "No, it's mine." But I stayed out of it, thinking instead of what might have been had I not wasted my wish. A laboratory filled with sensitive equipment. Men in white coats trembling with hope and wonder as they leaned forward, catching the sound of one small voice. "Come to think of it," the worm says, "I do remember seeing something suspicious."
“我想我们该走了，”休说，他和安掏出了钱包。关于谁来买单有一点小挣扎。“我请客。” “不，我请。” 但我没参与，而是想着如果我没浪费我的愿望，可能是什么样子。一个装满敏感设备的实验室。穿白大褂的男人颤抖着希望和惊奇，向前探着身子，捕捉着一个小声音。“说起来，”蠕虫说，“我确实记得看到了一些可疑的东西。”
David Sedaris. This story appears in his most recent book, Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim.
戴维·塞达里斯。这个故事出现在他最近的一本书《把你的家人打扮成灯芯绒和丹宁布》中。
[MUSIC - "THE GLOW WORM" BY THE MILLS BROTHERS]
[音乐 - 米尔斯兄弟的《发光虫》]
Act Four, Life Sentence. In 1989, a politician named Mike Miller, president of the Maryland State Senate, the kind of political veteran who does not slip up, made a comment to a reporter-- just a few sentences off the cuff-- that many political observers say put the kibosh on his chances to become governor.
第四幕，终身监禁。1989年，一位名叫迈克·米勒的政治家，马里兰州参议院院长，那种不会犯错的政坛老手，对一名记者发表了评论——只是随口说的几句话——许多政治观察家说这摧毁了他成为州长的机会。
The day this happened actually happened to be the day of a big political coming-out party for Miller, his first statewide fundraiser, to be held over in Baltimore. Miller comes from a district near DC. He'd sold over 2,000 tickets. Both US senators would be there, and the governor, and the mayor of Baltimore. But also, the same day, one of his law partners died at a desk in their law offices. So a lot was on his mind.
这件事发生的当天正好是米勒的一场大型政治出场派对的日子，他第一次全州范围的筹款活动，将在巴尔的摩举行。米勒来自华盛顿特区附近的一个选区。他卖出了超过2000张票。两位美国参议员都会出席，还有州长，以及巴尔的摩市长。但同样在这一天，他的一位法律合伙人在他们的律师事务所办公桌前去世了。所以他心里想的事很多。
And with all this happening, he gets a call from a TV reporter who was doing a story about a local gun control issue.
而就在所有这些事情发生的时候，他接到了一个正在做关于当地枪支管制问题的故事的电视记者的电话。
She came to my office, and I was sitting there very despondent about the law partner who had been found dead sitting just a few hours before in his chair in his office. And she comes in and starts stalking to me-- no mic check or no white-on-white check or anything like that. She said to me, "Why are you going to Baltimore?" In other words, you're not from this area in Baltimore, you're from Washington. Why are you going to Baltimore?
她来到我的办公室，我当时因为那位合伙人被发现死在办公室椅子上几个小时而非常沮丧。她进来开始跟我说话——没有麦克风测试，也没有白色衬衫测试之类的。她对我说，“你为什么要去巴尔的摩？” 换句话说，你不是巴尔的摩这个区域的人，你是华盛顿的人。你为什么要去巴尔的摩？
And I used some profanity-laced language about the city, defaming the city, which I love. But I was just using it to describe the need of the city in terms of jobs, in terms of economic development, in terms of education. But I said it in barnyard phraseology that-- which is sort of my standard nomenclature when I'm not in public life. I mean, I grew up in the country, you know?
我用了一些满是粗口的语言谈论这个城市，诋毁这个我所爱的城市。但我只是用它来描述这个城市在工作、经济发展、教育方面的需求。但我用的是一种谷仓式的措辞——这在我不处于公共生活时是我的标准命名法。我的意思是，我在乡下长大，你知道吧？
I don't mean to embarrass you for this thing. It happened 15 years ago. But let me just read the exact quote so people listening on the radio will know what we're talking about.
我不想因为这件事让你难堪。这发生在15年前。但让我读出那句确切的引语，这样收听广播的人就会知道我们在谈论什么。
OK.
好的。
You were asked why were you holding a fundraiser in Baltimore, and you said, "It helps educate my constituents as to why Baltimore needs the economic help. I mean, Baltimore is a goddamn ghetto. It's worse than inner-city Washington, DC. It is [BLEEP]." They beeped out the words like we're doing. And then you say, on tape, apparently, "I hope you're not going to play this on tape." And you laughed, and then you said, "I mean, it's a war zone. I mean, it's crack. I mean, it's dime bags of PCP. 1/4 of every kid is not in school each day. 50% of the kids that start out in school don't graduate. So looking at things from a statewide perspective, we really have to do things to help."
有人问你为什么在巴尔的摩举行筹款活动，你说，“这有助于教育我的选民为什么巴尔的摩需要经济帮助。我的意思是，巴尔的摩是个该死的贫民窟。它比华盛顿市中心还糟。它是个 [消音]。” 他们消音了这些词，就像我们正在做的一样。然后你在录音带上说，显然，“我希望你不打算把这个放在带子上录下来。” 然后你笑了，接着说，“我的意思是，它是个战区。我的意思是，它到处是快克毒品。我的意思是，它是一角钱一包的PCP（苯环利定）。每四个孩子里就有一个每天没去上学。学校里开始的孩子有50%没能毕业。所以从全州的视角来看，我们真的必须采取行动来帮助。”
Right. That's what I said.
没错。我就是那么说的。
But you didn't know they were actually rolling film?
但你当时不知道他们真的在开机录制？
No, absolutely not. But I didn't know that I had said anything wrong. I mean, I really didn't realize that I'd said anything wrong. I had no idea I'd said anything wrong. Nobody told me I was on television at the time. And so later on, she does her interview, and everything is fine. Doesn't mention anything, we don't follow up with it or anything like that.
不，绝对不知道。但我不知道我说了什么错话。我的意思是，我真的没意识到我说了什么错话。我完全不知道我说了什么错话。当时没人告诉我我在电视上。所以后来，她做了她的采访，一切都很好。没提到任何事，我们也没跟进或者类似的事情。
And then I get a call later on. Apparently, she'd got the tape, and she'd run to the Mayor of Baltimore, "Let me show you this." And she put it on the Baltimore stations, and then put it on the Washington stations. And they would make the announcement, "Be careful, have your children leave the room before you see this."
然后我后来接到了一个电话。显然，她拿到了带子，跑去找巴尔的摩市长，“让我给你看这个。” 她把它放在巴尔的摩的电视台播，然后又放在华盛顿的电视台播。他们会发布公告，“小心点，在你看到这个之前让你的孩子离开房间。”
Wow.
哇。
It was very traumatic. Because like I say, the people showed up at the fundraiser, and the mayor of Baltimore was there and the governor. And they couldn't believe that I'd said what I said.
那非常痛苦。因为就像我说的，人们出现在筹款活动上，巴尔的摩市长在那儿，州长也在那儿。他们无法相信我说了我所说的话。
So when something like this happens, is this just like a bomb going off? Does everything turn over in a minute?
所以当这种事发生时，这就像炸弹爆炸了吗？一切在瞬间翻转了吗？
Yes, very much so. I couldn't sleep. I left the hotel at 4 o'clock in the morning. I left my wife at the hotel. I couldn't sleep. I just had to get out of the city. I said, "Look, I'm leaving." And the doorman, he said, "Senator?" He says, "I don't understand this." He says, "You've always been great to Baltimore. I don't understand this." He says, "We'll figure a way out of this." He says, "You and I will figure a way out of this." This is the doorman at the hotel.
是的，非常如此。我无法入睡。我在凌晨4点离开了酒店。我把妻子留在了酒店。我睡不着。我只是得离开那个城市。我说，“看，我要走了。” 那个门房，他说，“参议员？” 他说，“我不明白这点。” 他说，“你对巴尔的摩一直很好。我不明白这点。” 他说，“我们会想出办法解决这个的。” 他说，“你和我会想出办法解决这个的。” 这是酒店的门房。
Wow.
哇。
And I said, "I appreciate it. Thank you very much." And anyway--
我说，“我很感激。非常感谢。” 总之——
Man, I've got to say, that's a bad number when--
伙计，我得说，那是个糟糕的数字，当——
He was a great guy, he was a great guy.
他是个很棒的家伙，他是个很棒的家伙。
When the doorman of the hotel is consoling you.
当酒店的门房在安慰你时。
The doorman of the hotel. He said, "Look, Senator, I'll help you. We'll figure a way--"
酒店的门房。他说，“看，参议员，我会帮你的。我们会想出办法——”
This is at 4:00 in the morning?
这是在凌晨4点？
Yes. So the next night, I'm on all the TV channels, 2, 11, 13. And anyway--
是的。所以第二天晚上，我出现在所有电视频道上，2、11、13。总之——
You mean going back and giving your side of it?
你的意思是回去并给出你的看法？
I went back in the city. I said, "Look, let me just explain this as best I can." And I explained it sort of the way I did to you. And the doorman goes-- I come back to the doorman because my wife had forgot her hat-- and he goes, "Senator, Senator," he said, "I knew you could do it, I knew you could do it." He said, "That country boy stuff gets them every time."
我回到了城里。我说，“看，让我尽可能解释一下。” 我解释的方式跟我对你解释的方式差不多。然后门房走过来——我回来找门房是因为我妻子忘了她的帽子——他走过来，“参议员，参议员，”他说，“我知道你能行的，我知道你能行的。” 他说，“那种乡村小子的那套总是很管用。”
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
So anyway, it was very traumatic for me. And like I say, a lot of people took offense that I used the word ghetto for example. And at the time, I didn't realize the connotation.
总之，这对我来说非常痛苦。就像我说的，很多人对我用了“贫民窟”这个词感到冒犯。当时，我没意识到它的内涵。
Yeah. Now, this happened on a night of an exploratory fundraiser for statewide office. What effect did this have on your career when you look back?
是啊。现在，这发生在你进行探索性全州办公室筹款活动的晚上。当你回顾过去时，这对你的职业生涯有什么影响？
If I were going to run for statewide office, it would certainly have set me back four to eight years. My adviser said, "If you had just taken that theme and expanded it and say what you really meant, you could have turned it into a positive." And I said, "Look, I don't really feel like doing that much explaining, and I don't want my mother to have to hear this statement again."
如果我要竞选全州办公室，那肯定会让我推迟四到八年。我的顾问说，“如果你当初采取那种主题并扩展它，说出你真正想说的，你本可以把它变成一个积极的东西。” 我说，“看，我真的不想花那么多时间去解释，而且我不希望我母亲被迫再听一次这个声明。”
Because wherever I campaign, it's going to be on TV. It's going to be on sound bites and TV ads and wherever, and I really don't want to see that again on television or in print.
因为无论我在哪里竞选，它都会出现在电视上。它会出现在音段和电视广告以及任何地方，我真的不想再在电视上或报纸上看到那个了。
This must have been one of those moments you ended up thinking about a lot afterwards, right?
这一定是那些你后来反复思考的时刻之一，对吧？
Oh, yeah. I mean, I just--
噢，是啊。我的意思是，我只是——
And what would you think? When you replay it in your head, what would you think about it?
你会想什么？当你在脑海中重演它时，你会怎么想它？
Well, as a politician, they give you these things, how you're supposed to deal with reporters and the press. And what you're supposed to say, and you're always on record. But I've never been able to follow that guideline for myself. I just-- People appreciate your candidness, but at the same time, it gets you in a lot of trouble.
嗯，作为一个政治家，他们会给你这些东西，关于你应该如何应对记者和媒体。以及你应该说什么，你总是处于记录中。但我从来没能为自己遵循那个准则。我只是——人们赞赏你的坦率，但同时，这会让你陷入很多麻烦。
Did you find that you were more careful in what you were saying afterwards?
你发现之后说话更谨慎了吗？
No. But I did find that there were certain reporters I wouldn't talk to anymore.
没有。但我发现有些记者我不再和他们说话了。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
And I saw that a couple years ago, in 2001-- that's 12 years after this happened-- the Baltimore papers did a big profile of you, a very flattering profile summarizing your legislative career. And this is one of the things that they mentioned. Not in a big way, but just as one of the things that had happened in your career. Is it dispiriting feeling like you're just never going to shake this, you know what I mean? When you retire, it's going to be there? In your obit, they're going to mention this in passing?
我看到几年前，2001年——那是在这事发生12年后——巴尔的摩报纸对你做了一个大的简介，一个非常恭维的简介，总结了你的立法生涯。这是他们提到的事情之一。不是以很大的方式，只是作为你职业生涯中发生的事件之一。感觉你永远无法摆脱这个，这种感觉令人沮丧吗，你知道我的意思吗？当你退休时，它也会在那里？在你的讣告里，他们会顺带提及这个？
It's going to be in my obituary. It's going to be in my obituary. There's a lot of things. And unfortunately, as somebody said, "History is lies agreed upon." Well, some of it's the truth, and you just have to take the good with the bad.
它会出现在我的讣告里。它会出现在我的讣告里。有很多事情。不幸的是，正如某人所说，“历史是达成的共识的谎言。” 嗯，其中一些是真相，你只能取其精华去其糟粕。
Mike Miller. He never did run for governor or for any other statewide office. He's a state senator, and now the longest sitting president of the Maryland State Senate in that body's history.
迈克·米勒。他确实从未竞选过州长或任何其他全州办公室。他是一名州参议员，现在是马里兰州参议院历史上任职时间最长的院长。
Well, our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey Dilts. Special thanks today to Luke Burbank and William Eville. You can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times, all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
嗯，我们的节目今天由斯塔莉·凯恩和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯和萨拉·科尼格。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯尔西·迪尔茨提供了制作帮助。今天特别感谢卢克·伯班克和威廉·埃维尔。您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。 《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who has a message for you, a very important message. And he wants you to listen very, very carefully. Are you ready?
WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他有一个信息给你，一个非常重要的信息。他希望你非常、非常仔细地倾听。你准备好了吗？
The homeless in the trees are mourning your economic decisions. Repent, dear King, or go to hell.
树上的无家可归者在哀悼你的经济决策。忏悔吧，亲爱的国王，否则下地狱吧。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。